the CEO hey Whitney the CEO and Founder
bumble is here
she's expanding her mission to empower
women her name is Whitney Wolfe heard
she created the dating app where women
who seek a heterosexual relationship
make the first move it was founded back
in 2014 and since then listen to these
numbers it's grown more than 55 million
users in 150 different countries who
have heard is also making internet safer
with bumbles new feature it's called
private detector it warns users about
inappropriate photos she joins us first
on CTM to reveal a new initiative called
moves making impact this is how it works
users pick a cause to support human
rights public policy or economic
development then bumble donates to women
making a difference in their community
Whitney will heard good morning
you were always thinking Missy always
thinking good morning good morning you
said this is the most important thing
that you and your company have ever done
and you've done a lot of great stuff why
is this the most important to you we are
so excited about this because we've
given women the opportunity to make the
first move love friendship business but
now their first moves can go beyond
themselves and impact a woman in the
world and that woman that were impacting
is impacting women in their community so
it has this catalytic effect we're so
excited about this it's rooted and
everything we've ever stood for well
it's about paying it forward and it's
about paying it forward and giving women
the opportunity to be change makers
through their daily lives and if we're
asking you to make the first move why
would we stop at empowering you yeah
let's let that impact women beyond that
this first moves can change your life
can't they certainly can they certainly
can and there's been a billion of them
yeah 1 billion think about all of the
opportunity that has done from that and
the fastest group of people making first
moves is over 40 years old what does
that tell us they are making a lot of
first moves and I think that's
incredible you know women of all ages
are making the first move which is
exciting when we started this you know
my business partner and I Andre Andreea
when we started this we both identified
that there was a missing link we're
making the internet safe for women
making it a place where women were
empowered they were safe and no one was
thinking about this in 2014 so the fact
that women of all ages have adopted this
goes to show it's a real need across the
board how is dating changed
Bombo came on market well first of all
dating is all about going after whatever
you're looking for there's all these old
archaic rules and we spoke about this
three years ago and I was he rule book
and bumbles really flipped the switch on
that so now the fact that a woman
doesn't have to sit around and wait to
be asked out or wait to be told to do
something which society has written for
us for centuries well you used to be
called aggressive or fast if you made
the first move
absolutely and now it's empowering yeah
that's refreshing no I actually
what do you call now if you make the
first move yeah what do you call now
you're called confidence the private
detector because we showed that earlier
how does that help keep women safe so as
I said my partner my founding partner in
the business Andre he's an incredible
mind and he has actually taken
technology to detect at ninety-eight
percent efficiency if a photo has
inappropriate content so a user might
receive a photo will be blurred so we do
not just allow photo sharing that is not
blurred we really have protective
measures and if there is something
inappropriate it will give you a warning
not to open this photo and then on the
flip side of that you know tech
companies really need to take action
here and do what they can by engineering
new products to keep the internet safe
but beyond that this is a big problem
anything RC yeah they're sending
pictures of themselves no we just heard
from Margaret on team Norwich she's
riding on the subway look on your phone
yeah air-dropped yeah women are being
with your riding and you get this
picture yeah you clearly don't want yes
and so you were testifying in Texas
recently to stop these unwanted sexual
folks yesterday I was on the Senate
floor in Texas we're trying to pass a
bill that would make the sending of
unsolicited new lewd photos illegal
I've never lie is it allowed digitally
when it's not allowed in the streets we
have indecent exposure laws you can go
to jail you get huge fines if you expose
yourself publicly in the streets we
should have the same rules digitally
people are operating on their phones we
need to keep the internet safe were they
receptive to that argument and it did
pass out of committee yesterday so we've
one more step we will take it to the
federal level next how do you see other
I understand that Facebook is coming out
with its own sort of dating
program app whatever it is how do you
see that sort of competition or what
they're getting involved in you know
it's fascinating the number one
recommended or asked for feature from us
about a year ago was non facebook login
our users did not want to join the
platform through Facebook they wanted to
join through their phone number we're in
an alternative way our users really are
not using Facebook even the +40 market
is not using facebook on our platform so
I really think there's a huge desire to
get away from just one exclusive social
media platform and there's really all
these other opportunities around that so
we welcome competition it means it's a
it's a really welcome comfort we do I
think it's a great industry I do think
there's a lot of competition something's
great but we're the only one that has
really said women come first we will
build a product we will do everything in
our power to change the lives of women
through technology and this new feature
moves making impact you can now be a
change maker by just using our product
Congrats - yes and grasses before we go
let the record show margaret declined
the photo yes yes salute photo that was
sent that is right thank you thank you
so much oh great thank you
okay smart grits mother's watching